season two of glow available for
streaming on Netflix right now
allisonbrianne a cast of thousands
including this man who plays an awkward
superfan named cupcake he was also ham
in the Sandlot it's good to see you
Patrick rena good to see you thank you
so all your characters are named after
food in a certain way yeah yeah ham
cupcake you know it's a good combats a
good Connors art why not unbelievable to
25th anniversary
yeah I'll believe it this no I can't can
you I have not really no sometimes it
feels that way and sometimes it's a
little strange no you playing in a
superfan in Glo D are there any Sandlot
super fans sure so it was great research
I you know just channeled the inner
Sandlot super fan said so what's the
artist except i cupcake was a fan of a
beautiful woman these guys are fans of
dudes playing baseball it's a little bit
it's a little bit different apples and
oranges yeah yeah to say the least yet
but it's interesting there's a story
that we saw recently in which by the way
Brockman you're wearing a Sandlot shirt
I am nice during that Sandlot shirt so
there was somebody what was the story
here Oh Patrick was walking down the
street and saw someone wearing that
you're killing me smalls t-shirt you
asked him to take a photo right yeah
well I was with Tom gyri who played
smalls and the line obviously is you're
killing me smalls and it just it's a
whole lot better when we're together we
we have not spent time together in 25
years so anyway we're in Manhattan and
the Lower East Side and this guy starts
walking toward us and I'm like aw Tom
check this out so we get about 15 feet
apart and I got a nice shirt buddy and
then we sort of past each other and
start walking back and he goes what and
I went yeah and then I just got all
crazy
oh that's me on the shirt he's smalls
but and then I just went dude I gotta
get a photo of this do you mind if I get
a photo and then I write at the end I
think he started realizing because he
started a secret video and I was like ah
all right
so how I'm looking at the gentleman
so it looks like he's a millennial like
he's a teen or something yeah he might
be Jen's ëcoz Millennials are a little
up there now so true good I think he's
the next generation I think even
Millennials do know but so you Patrick
Renault who played ham yeah he's in the
law and you're killing me smalls is
walking down New York City with the
actual smalls the dude has the shirt by
mere happenstance yeah a shirt of you
saying you're killing me smalls is being
warned yes guy did not know no glue or
the other guy sweetest guy had no idea I
think we scared him a little bit to be
honest make it up what about doing what
are we doing why do you think the
sandlot has such staying power do you
think you know I I don't know it's I
think partly because baseball is more
than just a sport you know it's sort of
just a nostalgic sport in itself as part
of the reason and then I think also
because the movies not just about
baseball it's about growing up and you
know what what are the big parts of it
is inclusion and I think that strikes a
chord with people you know you know
Benny make sure that Scottie smalls is
included and the rest of us kind of our
first instinct is to not and it's just
that not that we were bullies because we
weren't but it's it just has that thing
where the that handsome stud dude he
brings the other guy in and there's
something that gives you the chills
about that what what was it like on the
set shooting that I mean how old were
you well I was one of the older ones I
was 13 between 13 and 14 it was like
just we were filming baseball over the
summer so it was great we just had an
amazing time it was hot it was half
baseball half acting we only could fill
me eight hours a day cuz we were younger
that's right then we just you know party
that all together every night and now
look no not not that kind of party
13-year old part is Los Angeles well
this was also the 90s so it wasn't I
mean who knows what the kids are doing
these days apparently there are in
shirts and they have no idea what
they're wearing believe that what a
story that yeah it was pretty great I I
hesitated in posting it to cuz I was
like oh I don't know is this funny and
then a friend of mine said no no you got
to and I'm glad I did cuz people got a
real kick out of and then you threw out
a first pitch correct
my first first pitch ever it's so
frightening
well I've caught a lot of first pitches
because I was the catcher yeah I've done
that plenty of times right but I threw
out a first pitch yes yeah I caught the
director's pitch at the Dodger game ok
which is cool but it's it's more fun to
throw the first pitch after a strike yes
from the mound I did not go in front of
the mound for you they said aim high
yeah exactly yeah and I play baseball so
you know it was a changeup it wasn't
with a heater but I still at least you
didn't I didn't bounce it they did about
I mean we just had akbar baja be a
miller here just yesterday from American
Ninja Warrior and he's the one who's
essentially spiked it in Philadelphia
have you not seen it we're not all
screen right here I mean this is our now
Oh No but that's no 50-cent right there
that don't fit II know I mean that's ii
$0.25 i mean that's a that's a dime he's
really man i saw another one where a
dude threw it over and clocked a guy in
the head the other day right whatever i
want there was a one from from boston
where he hit somebody directly in the
jewels right yeah right in the kids
rough man and then george w bounced it
didn't he
no george w where did he throw a strike
I mean I was this is the greatest first
pitch of all time and I think he bounced
it another time okay in the last couple
but you can tell he knows how to play to
he's got skills I you know we have some
facts about the Sandlot that we would
like to know if you can let's do it sure
that it's true or false let's play a
celebrity to Rafael here we go Patrick
grant a fact number one the chewing
tobacco was made of beef jerky and
licorice true or false that's true and
it was awful that sounds positively
terrible well does anyone like black
licorice anyone
I got eyes nevermind it I don't first
but I wouldn't want to mix it with beef
jerky exactly yeah it was like an awful
break horrible and it made me almost
legitimately throw up it was so Terry
you cannot have either as a gentlemen
knife jerky but I can't do licorice okay
they could be cruel to kids back then
now or you got a true false Patrick
Renault during the filming of the pool
scene
and it was overcast in the water was 56
degrees true the we filmed in Salt Lake
City in the summer and it was blazing
hot for the entire three months except
one day when we were all in the pool and
you can look at shot Celia party who
plays squints and it probably was a
little bit of nerves because he was
about to smooch you know Wendy
peppercorn marley shelton and he was
chattering from just the ice cold water
and you can see in it he's his teeth are
chattering and he's shivering it's great
so us ham get in the pool and said I was
fine come on you're fine 36 is nobody
that's nothing true or false many of the
young actors snuck into a theater to
watch Basic Instinct during the filming
I hate that story Marty York tells that
story I don't remember
I'm not gonna say it's false because it
probably did happen however I have no
recollection of doing it so I'm not
going to confirm you remember Basic
Instinct and Sharon Stone's
interrogation scene I would too I don't
I don't remember it
did they not invite you Patrick maybe
hardly pause maybe that's what's
happening here wait a minute we're onto
something
thank you aim to get in you know 25th
anniversary is over it's about to say to
whom by a feeling of the quarter-century
reunion yeah I think that's what it is
they tell the story and I was the only
one left at home by the way Oh Paul so
don't sleep on what Jeanne Tripplehorn
in that film as well yeah on that see
now that's something I would have
remembered you dementia yeah he was
red-hot yeah no question about it
Newman that scene Newman is in the scene
the interrogation scene that's right
yeah Wow last fact true or false
Patrick Renner you as ham we're the last
kid cast in the film is that true yeah I
think it is true I was it was me and I
think Tom gyri were the last to they had
a ham originally and it didn't work out
so I auditioned for for the part on like
a Friday and then my callback was the
next day and I just had to go meet the
guys and make sure that I got along with
them so that was basically the second
audition was hey come meet these dudes
because you're gonna play baseball with
him for a month not me for three months
so who was the ham that did
we know I don't I it might have not even
been a person I think they switched
roles I think yeah
Umar is Marty York yeah I think he was
originally cast as ham or something and
then got switched to yaaaa and maybe
they were one guy short so they always
needed a guy but how are you enjoying
glow I mean it's a hell of a show it's a
great it's a great retro look back in
the day and I would never have thought
the gorgeous ladies of wrestling let's
do a show on Netflix about it but it's
works it's phenomenal well I think it
works cuz the those that cast of
characters is so great and the writing
is so great and some of my favorite
shows to watch are the 30 minute ones I
have a 15 month old son now so I don't
have a lot of time for anything
okay so smalls yeah I have a small so if
you give me 28 minutes I can I can do
that and comedy keeps me awake so I'm
not falling asleep you know so that's
one of my favorite things okay so you're
streaming it you're streaming it with
with your kid yeah I got I got a new
second season myself now that I'm on it
I don't like to watch myself too much
what are you gonna make s'mores with
your kid I'll give him a few years I
showed him the Sandlot the other day and
he he recognized me but I think the age
is like four or five when they really
start appreciate it yeah so give it a
few years that'll be great I mean
that'll be great we're not sure there's
dad in the Sandlot yeah which is the
staying power great to see you Pat yeah
thank you for having on come back
anytime you I would love to that Patrick
Rena on on Twitter we're back in 60
seconds with your phone calls to check
out the poll question and we will go
down a game-show wormhole that's gonna
happen when we come back
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience